kannst du bitte im intro nicht so
schreiben ich hab mir und meinen letzten
videos ein paar kommentare rausgesucht
die wir heute gemeinsam reagieren werden
und ich würde sagen wir regt an mit dem
herzen kommentar du bist schon ein
ordentliches stück scheiße jedoch muss
ich da ganz einfach sagen also summa
summarum look zeigen
also ich finde luca als frau ganz hübsch
er kommt aber wahrscheinlich auf den
snap gezogen indem ich sie im filter
benutzt habe der mich zur frau gemacht
hat aber freut mich dass wenigstens du
mich hübsch findet an der stelle für
dich hier nochmal ein exklusives foto
von mir mit dem filter endlich hat luca
sein wahres ich gefunden hat da noch die
minute 531 dazu geschrieben das heißt
ich würde mal einfach unter dem video
schauen was da an der stelle passiert
ist darum hoch wenn ihr auch schon mal
klappen durch euer zimmer gelaufen sei
wir machen allerdings direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten kommentar und weiß dass
dieser hier
wenn ich gross werde mehr anzeigen will
ich auch klatschen durchs zimmer gehen
luca meine community besteht nur aus
vollidioten ich zu mir selbst ja aber
nur weil du auch einer
kannst du mal wieder auf tech talks
reagieren weil du es bist die liebe all
right toastbrot der name ist ja fast
beschissen als luca weil du es bist
werden wir nun zusammen auf tik tok
reagieren
[Musik]
das sind die worte bei den ersten 20
minuten
schauen wir mal wie lange das video geht
fünf minuten 48 also keine ahnung wie
bei dir die zeit rechnung funktioniert
aber wenn von einem video das fünf
minuten 48 geht deiner meinung nach die
ersten 20 minuten nur das wort aha drin
vorkommt dann bist du schon nicht gerade
die heldts die glühbirnen lampengeschäft
ich kann besser als du klavier spielen
ich bin im vierten heft sie ist im
vierten heft keine ahnung was für eine
show nur du gehst aber im vierten heft
zu sein ist glaube ich schon krass
außerdem weiß jeder dass ich der beste
klavierspieler der welt bin
kannst du pokemon unser vier spielen
[Musik]
ich spiele gerade pokémons a4 machen
allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten kommentar und zwar diesen hier
bin ich früh cooler live stream gestern
an sich ein komplett normaler kommentar
die sache ist nur das profilbild habe
ich hier verpixelt ist ein halbes
nacktfoto und ihr name ist julia i love
ihr wisst glaube ich was da steht
und das ist nicht der einzige kommentar
unter meinen letzten videos der in so
eine richtung geht sondern übels viele
kommentare sind mit solchen sexuellen
inhalten einfach voll also der kommentar
selbst nicht mal sondern lediglich der
name und das profilbild man geht man auf
das profil drauf dann sind dort
irreführende links irgendwelchen
komischen webseiten also was wollt ihr
von mir ich feierlich luca aber ich
freue mich endlich mal dass das video
unter zehn minuten ist
also erstmal wird dass das hier mit zwei
s geschrieben aber um jetzt noch mal
kurz auf deinen kommentar einzugehen und
zwar wurde dieser kommentar untermain
gestern hochgeladenes video gepostet das
ging nur fünfeinhalb minuten und er sagt
er freut sich dass das video nicht zehn
minuten geht
wo ist da der sinn also ich mir
natürlich klar wenn ich wiederhole dass
ich nach zehn minuten geht dann weil ich
dann natürlich war der werbeanzeigen
rein weil ich einfach doppelt oder
dreifach so lange dem video gesehen habe
wie beispielsweise meinem gestrigen
hochgeladenen video was nur die hälfte
davon gingen allerdings und ich weiß
dass ich der einzige bin der so denkt
aber wenn ich ein youtube abonniert habe
und seine videos feiert dann würde ich
mich immer dafür entscheiden dass er
lieber einen zehn minuten video mit
werbung darin hochlädt als 1 5 minuten
video wo keine werbung drin ist
versteht ihr was ich meine damit eure
meinung da wirklich mal sehr
interessieren also schreibt zwar ohne
die kommentare fünf minuten videos oder
zehn minuten videos was findet ihr
besser allerdings machen wir direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten kommentar und
zwar also der hilferuf laut luca hat bei
mir nicht geklappt der kommentar wurde
ebenfalls unter meinen gestern
hochgeladen das video gepostet und ich
glaube die meisten kennen nachdem ich
mein gestriges video hochgeladen habe
habe ich unten in die kommentare
geschrieben dass jeder der mal in not
ist einfach laut luca schreien muss und
an alle ich zu hilfe und ich kann es mir
ehrlich gesagt wirklich nicht erklären
warum es bei dir liebe thekla olivia
nicht geklappt hat bin ich einfach ganz
laut rufen oh hallo da wissen wir ja da
bin ich ja ja da bin ich wohl wo ist der
name kernkraft an luca auf das thema
wollte ich auch noch ganz kurz eingehen
und zwar hat er schon mitbekommen jahr
meine damen und herren der name
contractor ist geschichte zum newcomer
im endeffekt nehmen
ich habe meinen youtube-kanal namen von
crafter schrägstrich luca auf nur noch
luca umbenannt habe also das konkreter
gelöscht aus meinem kanal namen ich habe
den kontrakt damals gewählt da ich vor
einigen jahren nur minecraft auf meinem
kanal hochgeladen habe da ich jetzt
allerdings seit einigen jahren mehr real
live content und andere games hochladen
natürlich ab und zu auch nochmal
minecraft hat sich mein content
allerdings nahezu grundlegend verändert
hat habe ich mir gedacht hey ich beende
hiermit das kapitel contractor und
nennen mich luca weil der name luca ist
mein tisch ist nadal und steht besser
für meinen kanal meine videos der name
contra finde ich bin immer noch die
gleiche person
ich werde immer noch den gleichen
content hochladen die gleichen videos
nur der name ist halt weg und ich hoffe
keiner wird
will auch dass er ein tutorial macht ich
bin zwar nicht der sportlichste aber hey
ich kann es ja versuchen er hat ja auch
wieder eine minute rein geschrieben und
zwar minute 1 doppelpunkt 09
das heißt wir schauen noch mal was da in
meinem letzten video passiert ist
[Musik]
okay das kann ich euch kurz eben
erklären das ist eigentlich relativ easy
und zwar braucht ihr zu helfen
der trick ist eigentlich ziemlich
einfach und zwar brauchen wir als erstes
erstmal ein skateboard also seit sie
klein ist hat man kauft euch einwenden
dass ein skateboard haben dann das
wichtige ist und dass verbrauchern ein
video gesehen das ist wirklich einen
sehr sehr festen stand auf dem board
habt vorlegen das muss auch der hälfte
der hexe sonst in festen standort machen
was wir wollen auf dem skateboard oder
runter zu fahren
und nun kommen wir zur wichtigsten sagen
bei dem dann zutritt und waren der trick
wie bereits gesagt schon fest auch in
meinem herzen mit dem board mit den
hinteren fuß
das heißt jetzt haltet ihr einfach still
[Musik]
also also bitteschön für das tutorial
hier falls ihr wissen wollt wie ich noch
die andere drehung noch zurück gemacht
haben dann schreibt er unter die
kommentare dann zeige ich euch das im
nächsten video und jetzt kommt erstmal
der nächste kommentar halo könntest du
mal auf black pink reagieren black pink
ist eine hip hop girlgroup mit vier
mitgliedern new york la können uns
direkt mal anschauen
mal
in der woche luca bringt einen rudi im
sommer raus
wie nicht der einzige der goodies zu
jeder jahreszeit trägt der kommentar
wurde unter das video gepostet in dem
ich euch diesen rudi hier vorgestellt
habe der neopren die der im ersten sechs
landen wird
neben diesem neopren rudi wird es
außerdem auch ein neues pop socket geben
also mit einem bunten smiley sowie der
da hinten in etwa wird auch noch dieser
neue smiley hier launch dieses mal die t
shirt hier wird auch noch launischen und
auch noch dieses look to you better t
shirt das heißt im heutigen video habe
ich euch zum ersten mal alle 59 produkte
gezeigt die am ersten sechs leichen
werden
doch gott das monster wieder an der
stelle möchte ich euch jetzt allerdings
auch endlich verraten was es mit diesem
junitag schriftzug auf vielen teilen zu
bedeuten hat und zwar ist jupiter der
name der kollektion also der überbegriff
der fünf produkte die am ersten sechs
und fünfzehn meinem job lounge werden
einem was wir uns dabei einfach gedacht
haben ist
ich habe selber in den letzten monaten
sehr viel mitbekommen wie mobbing und
rassismus stattgefunden hat nicht nur an
schulen sondern allgemein im
öffentlichen leben und deswegen haben
wir uns gedacht dass wir bei jedem
verkauften neuen produkt zwischen dem
ersten sechs und den ersten 17 2009/10
jetzt in lucka shop dass wir ein euro
spenden werden an einen verein der sich
gegen rassismus einsetzt wie kein
anderer und zwar die stiftung gegen
rassismus das heißt pro verkauftes neues
produkt werden wir einen euro spenden an
die stiftung gegen rassismus und hoffen
dadurch ein zeichen setzen zu können
dass also einfach die erklärung dafür
warum die meter auf einigen produkten
draufsteht
das ist einfach der kollektions name der
neuen produkte und werden uns einfach
gedacht hey egal ob hellere hautfarbe
dunkle hautfarbe egal ob jemand aus
deutschland kommen dort aus irgendeinem
anderen land wir sind alles menschen und
diesen verein stiftung gegen rassismus
möchten wir unterstützen und entscheide
mich dass heute wieder ist alex auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn ich
meine reaktion auf einige kommentare die
unter meinen letzten videos gepostet
wurde gefallen hat das unbedingt einen
daumen hoch hier unter dem video hier da
klickt auf abonnieren
falls sie noch kein teil der lupo seit
und falls sie schon abonnent sind dann
klick gern auf die glocke denn dann
bekommt er automatisch kostenlos eine
benachrichtigung aufs handy sobald ich
neues video lade mensch ist das wahnsinn
[Musik]